- Have you ever met Matt, I
was gonna ask, first of all?
- No and I'm so grateful to both of you.
You've given me so much
joy over my lifetime, so,
over my lifetime, I make it
sound a thousand years old,
but I was so excited to come today
and be sandwiched by you.
- Oh cool, that's actually
why I love the panel,
'cause I feel like people don't generally,
everybody thinks everybody
knows each other,
like you go to some kind of
celebrity barbecue weekly
or something, yeah.
I don't know anyone.
- I gotta take off.
(laughing)
- I actually don't wanna be here.
So wait, you and I are
actually gonna be taking
Joey Tribiani down in a
Friends game, are you ready?
- I know, well, we can be
nice to him now, though,
'cause, you know, then
we'll kick his ass later.
- Okay.
- Oh, okay, okay,
I was like, "Wait,
"we're not gonna be
nice about it, Bellamy,"
but then you got there,
okay, you got there.
No, you loved Friends though, right?
- Oh yeah, how about you guys?
(audience cheering)
- It's such a good show,
yeah, such a good show.
But today's show is a
love letter to New York
and you just moved there, right?
- Yes, I love it so much,
it my heart's home, I do.
(audience clapping)
- So you didn't grow up
there, right, though?
- No, I grew up in North Carolina,
Asheville, North Carolina,
in the mountains.
- [Kelly] Our family live in Asheville.
- Oh no, are you serious?
- We have family in Asheville
and really in Granite Falls,
yeah, yeah, yeah.
- I didn't know that,
but to get this job, it was
always like a holy grail,
you know, to get a job that
wonderful in New York city
and now I just sit, I have
a tiny, little balcony
and I, you know, overlooks an avenue
and I just look an happy cry.
- Wait, so your apartment
doesn't look like Monica, or Joey's?
- My apartment looks like this table.
(laughing)
And I stand here sometimes
and here sometimes
and here sometimes and I love it!
- Have you shopped for apartments?
Did you shop for 'em or did you find--
- I did it all on StreetEasy.
Have you guys ever used that StreetEasy?
'Cause I was here, so
I wasn't in New York.
I had to ask my friends,
"Will you go to this
open house on Wednesday?"
But yeah, I was like,
till my thumbs fell off,
that's how I found my little apartment
and then it was all Ikea and Amazon
and I built my bed and
my dresser and all of it.
(audience cheering)
- I love Ikea.
- I know, me too.
- You know what though?
I think, Ikea, you should never,
you can really tell who
your true friends are.
I don't think you should
build furniture like that
with loved ones.
(laughing)
I feel like it ends poorly.
- I mean, 'cause they always say, like,
it's that little cartoon that is like,
"This is a two person job,"
which I feel is angry
at the single people,
so I do not accept.
- So, Matt, do you have a store place
that you're crazy about, like
Ikea or anything like that?
- You know, when we were doing Friends,
if we went to work and
we had a photo shoot,
or doing press for the show,
it was really consuming,
so when that ended, I kind of said,
"I need to go out and
reengage with the world,"
and I discovered this place called Target,
anybody heard of that?
(audience clapping)
- I love Target.
- That was like, "Oh my God."
You can get baloney and motor
oil and pillows and fridges.
- And jeans, you can get everything
and here's the thing about Target though,
it's like Alice in
Wonderland, the rabbit hole,
you just go down, because
I go in for a spatula
and I come out with 500 dollars
worth of crap I don't need.
- Yeah, when we shopped at
Whole Foods, was whole paycheck,
like that's my whole
paycheck, like, Target
and there's always something cute, yeah.
- I'm in Target anonymous now.
(laughing)
- [Bellamy] I'm working through
it, I'm working through it.
- But, I have to talk to you about this
because I completely stormed
into your dressing room.
(laughing)
'Cause you kept me up till
1:30 in the morning last night.
I was so excited to see Prodigal Son
and then I heard you were
coming on today and I was like,
"God, I've been dying to
watch this for so long."
I was like, "I'll just watch
one episode, just so I know."
Seven episodes later, I'm in my bed
and my husband is snoring and I'm like,
"I just have to know if,"
and I don't wanna ruin it,
so I'm not gonna say it,
I'm not gonna say it, but
I had to know something
and they kept teasing you
and I had to keep watching
and it's so good.
It's the highest rated new show right now.
- It is, we're so lucky, yes, yes.
- It's so good!
- We love making it,
we love doing it.
I dunno if you guys have
seen it yet, it's sort of,
it's a show that asks the question
what if Hannibal Lecter were your father?
- Or husband.
- Or your husband,
Michael Sheen plays that
character, he's my husband
and he gets carted off to
Hannibal Lecter land in like, 98.
- He might secretly be psycho.
- He's a very good actor.
- I am like, "Whoa."
- Let's not anger him.
(laughing)
And Tom Payne from Walking Dead
plays our son, all grown up
and now he's a profiler
trying to atone for
the sins of his father.
Yeah and it's got the family setup,
so it has heart and humor,
but it's got enough horror
to keep you awake at night.
- Yeah, but it has humor too,
even the serial killer
kinda humor is funny
and I'm laughing at it and I'm like,
"That's not funny, that's horrible."
- But they make it funny.
- They do.
- You know, you gotta
laugh to get through.
- I love it, I am very
excited for this show for you.
I mean, you're just going
from one hit show to the next,
so there you go, universe, you're welcome.
(laughing)